in problem 133
a certain country had a total annual
expenditure of 1.2
times 10
to the 12th power last year
if the population of the country was 240
million last year so the population
is 240
million what was the per capita
expenditure
so 240 million what is that that's a
million is
10 to the sixth power
right so this is
240
times 10
to the sixth
right
and that's the same thing as 24
times 10 to the 7th right i just took 10
from here and multiplied 10 there
and that is equal to 2.4 times 10 to the
8th power
right divide this by 10 and multiply
this by 10 you get the same number so
2.4 times 10 to the 8th so the per
capita income is going to be equal to
the total
the total
annual expenditure so 1.2 times 10 to
the 12th
divided by the the population 2.4 times
10 to the 8th
let's see 1.2 divided by 2.4 that's
equal to 0.5 right that's exactly half
of that times 10 to the 12th divided by
10 to the eighth you subtract the
exponents that's 10 to the fourth
and that's not one of the answers so we
could write this as
so we can multiply this times 10 and
divide this by 10. so this becomes
5 times 10 to the third
10 to the third is a thousand so 5 times
a thousand is equal to five thousand
dollars
or five thousand whatever dollars in
annual expenditure per capita and that's
choice e
problem 144
144 134 sorry
a certain rectangular window is twice as
long as it is wide
so twice as
twice as long as it is wide
so if this is the width
its length is 2 times the width
if its perimeter is 10 feet then its
dimensions are so its perimeter is going
to be w plus w plus the two lengths
right so its perimeter is going to be
2w plus 2w
plus w plus w and that's going to be
equal to
10
if we add up all the w's that's 2
4
5 6 so we get 6 w is equal to ten
w is equal to ten over six
which is equal to five over
three five over three feet
and so its dimensions are five over
three and then the two w so the length
is 2 times that which is 10 over 3.
so it's 10 over 3
by 5 over 3.
and that's choice b they say 5 over 3 by
10 over 3 but same same thing so choice
b
problem 135
135
okay interesting let's see if i can draw
this
diagram so we start this is x
and then they goes there it has a
diamond
diamond like that
and it goes like that
then we have another diamond
let's see i don't know what this is all
for yet but it looks interesting
it goes like that
then
goes like that
there's a diamond there
it's like there
this line goes like that
goes like that like that
and like that
and then finally
we're at y
the diagram above shows the various
paths along which a mouse can travel
from point x
to
can travel from point x where it is
released to point y
where does reward with the food pellet
how many different paths from x to y
can the mouse take if it goes directly
from x to y without retracing any
point along a path
so let's see there's only one way it has
to go here
so we're only at one path right now one
path
and then it can either go this way to
get here or it could go this way right
so to get here
there's how many different paths like
that or like that so at this point
there's two two ways to get right there
there's one way to get here two ways to
get here
now
two ways to get here that means that
there's two ways to get here
now
how many ways are there to get here
well there's each of the two ways to get
there and now we have two each of those
co in combination with each of these two
ways so there's four ways to get here
you could think of it like this you
could go the top one and the top that's
one top and the bottom two
bottom and the bottom three
bottom in the top four so you could just
multiply how many ways it to get here
and then how many more ways to get from
here to here right from here to here
there's two possible ways and there's
already two ways to get here so you
could multiply the two so there's four
ways to get here
four ways to get here
to get from here to here there are three
ways right one two and three
but since there are already four ways to
get here for with each of those four
ways we can go in three different ways
so we multiply four times threes there's
12 ways to get right here
if there's 12 ways to get here there's
12 ways to get to y
so the answer is c
12.
problem one let me see it's 136.
if the operation circle with a dot in it
is defined by
x circle with a circle with a dot
y
is equal to the square root of x y
for all positive numbers x and y so
they're saying x and y are greater than
zero that's good because that ensures
that we have a positive under the square
root sign
then
they want to know what
5
circle with a dot
45
circle with a dot
60 is equal to
well 5 circle 45 that's equal to
the square root of 5 times 45
right that's that
and whatever that is we're circling with
that right
so what you do when you have circle
x circle y you multiply the 2 and then
you take the square root so we would
multiply 60 times this and take the
square root of the whole thing
so you would multiply
so let's see well actually let's just
simplify this this is equal this right
here is equal to the square root of 5
times 45
which doesn't look simplifiable at face
value but if you think about it 45 is 9
times 5 you just want to take out any
perfect squares you have there so that's
equal to
5 times 9 times 5
and that's equal to square root of what
25
times 9.
and that is equal to the square root of
25 times the square root of 9 and that's
equal to 5 times 3 which is equal to 15.
so this simplifies to 15
and 15 circle
dot circle whatever you want to call it
60 is equal to the square root
of 15
times
60. and let's see if we can if we can
somehow turn this into some type of a of
a perfect square let's see 4.
yeah let's say let's rewrite this as
15 60 is the same thing as 15 times 4
right
so this is equal to the square root of
15 times 15
times the square root of 4.
the square root of 15 times 15 that's
going to be 15
times 2 which is equal to 30.
and that's choice a
problem 137 i'll do it in yellow
problem 137 a bar over a sequence of
digits in a decimal indicates that the
sequence repeats indefinitely what is
the value of
10 to the fourth
minus
10
to the 12th
times
0.0012
and then this one tool just keep
repeating keep repeating over and over
again
so let's see what we can do so what's 10
to the fourth
let's think about it this way let's
let's distribute this right so what's
ten to the fourth that's ten thousand
so what's ten thousand
ten thousand
times
this number right
well point
let's point zero zero
one two
so the way the easiest way and this one
two keeps repeating so we'll think about
that in a second so what's one two times
twelve what's twelve times
uh
ten thousand well it's a hundred and
twenty thousand right one hundred and
twenties
it's twelve with four zeros through
three four right which is 120 000. we
have four numbers behind the decimal
point so it gets us there
right you might say okay we're done it's
12 but it's actually not 12 because it's
actually 1 2 1 2 1 2 the 1 2s just keep
going so you should actually it would
actually be 1 2
1 2 1 2
and then one twos keep repeating on like
that right fair enough i think you
understand why right
this is this is would be if we just had
one one two times ten thousand but if
the one twos kept going then these
wouldn't be zeros these would be
one twos right
hopefully that makes sense to you maybe
there's an easy way to think about it so
what's a hundred
we'll use the same logic what's 100
times point zero zero
one two
let's see that is
that is well actually i could probably
get on this a simpler way but let's just
continue this way
so 12 times 100 is 1200
and we have four numbers behind the
decimal point
right one two three four
one two three four
and of course
it's it's not just point one two it'll
just keep going point one two one two
will just keep going right
so we have this times this which is this
minus this times this i'm just
distributing it so
if i just subtract this from that minus
0.12
oh wait wait no i this is
i wrote this right this is this was 12
right because we said 12
times 10 000 is 120 000. we had one two
three four behind the decimal one two
three four so it's 12 right but since we
had multiple one twos behind it becomes
12.12 i don't know what i was doing with
this right here so the answer so let me
write that again sorry i'm doing this a
little bit messy so
.0012 repeating
times 10 to the fourth is going to be
equal to 12.12
repeating and we're going to subtract
.0012
repeating
times
10 squared and that is equal to
0.12 repeating so if i subtract out the
0.12 repeating from 12.12 repeating i'm
just going to be left with 12.
and hopefully that's one of the answers
it is choice
e
see you in the next video